the bells toll noon nothing changes here
on kent street noon ottawa mayors
deadline to see clear evidence of trucks
moving out of residential zones after
announcing a deal with convoy organizers
nothing's changed like
the mandates are still here so i'm not
going um
i'm not afraid of any fines or anything
coming my way we have a point to prove
those staying put have reinforcements
this family hands out valentine's treats
this couple drove seven hours to give
out thousands in cash they need money
right they gotta eat they gotta they're
not working at one of the supply camps
outside the core complete with saunas no
movement either i'm not going anywhere
but as the afternoon wore on a number of
trucks did move some rolled off o'connor
street filling in spots in front of
parliament hill this is where we want to
be we're on parliament it took us two
weeks to get here very happy a very big
day for us the motivation has been there
there since day one
but there's
people that leave and people that come
so you got to fill up the gap to hold
the line protester direction is still
hazy ottawa mayor jim watson shared a
letter from organizer tamara lytch green
lighting the residential move out but
with an ever-evolving multi-pronged
convoy structure conflicting messaging
abounds yes the one with tamara's name
on it it's a lie do not leave the
residential areas you are good to go
stand your ground
lynch
king company take a hike you don't talk
for me mayor watson declined an
interview he's faced some criticism for
his offer to meet with protesters he
tweeted that they have begun to act on
their commitment noting it is a complex
multi-day operation this as the city
secured an injunction aimed to stop
illegal idling fires and noise but
whether and how they enforce that is
another question so too is what will
happen to this new influx of trucks
behind me parked even closer together
making any potential towing operation an
even bigger challenge abigail beeman
global news ottawa